Guys, let's go ahead and build our list. So hop over to the screen with me really quick.
Okay, now that we're here, what we're going to do is obviously need to open up,
hit the download, you know, open up the prospecting list template. And what I recommend doing is
having it on your Google Drive and just having the template and making a copy every time. So
that's what I've done is I made a copy of the prospecting list template and then I just name
it accordingly. So what I'll typically do is like, I'll do this for multiple cities. I'll do one of
these for like a state or a niche. So for example, this one would be, maybe I would do this one for
concrete, right? So I would do prospecting list template, concrete, niche, right? And then down
here, I would name this just a simple way to keep this straight. I do Queen Creek AZ, something like
that. You can do it however you want. I've done everything, all the above, okay? Next thing you're
going to want to do, it's very, very simple, very cut and dry, is I want you to put your keywords
in here. And again, just tying this all together, if you remember when I talked, when we talked about
the keyword list and why it's so important to have that dialed in and I really hope you guys
didn't skip that part or didn't breeze over it. But if you did that correctly, everything else
becomes easier. We use it over and over and over and over. And so hopefully you guys listen to what
I said. Take that keyword list, take your core keywords and put them in here because those are
what we're going to use to search to find these businesses. And then what's very, very simple is
if you remember when we were doing the due diligence market research, we typed in the terms
with the city. So concrete contractors, Queen Creek, concrete patio, Queen Creek,
Queen Creek concrete, yada, yada, yada. So type all of them in just like we did in the beginning.
Again, take your keywords, type them in with the city and state. And then it's really, really simple
is we're just going to start looking, okay? We're going to start looking for businesses that are
running ads. So for example, for those of you that aren't familiar with how this works,
it's going to say ad. It's going to say ad. And once in a while, you're going to see an ad here
in the, what's called the Google local listing or the Google my business or the Google business
profile or whatever it's called at the time of you seeing this video. Sometimes you'll see an ad
in here. So if there's four companies inside of this, that's because somebody's running an ad.
Okay? So pay attention to that. And what you're going to start doing is start looking for businesses
to add. Now one thing, number one, do not click on people's ads. That pisses me off when people
do it to me. And I'm just really weird about that. Don't click on people's ads. So just because you're
being lazy, don't do that. Okay? So it says, if it says the diamond solutions, what I did is I
literally went and typed in the diamond solutions.com. Okay? And you're just going to start going through
and you're going to start adding businesses to your list here. Okay? So you're going to want to
do the business name, the URL. And again, we're trying to make this easy. Keep in mind the reason
we're building this list is so that when leads start coming in, first of all, to validate,
Hey, there are people paying for ads. Number two, when leads start coming in, we already have a list.
We could just call. So we want to make this as easy as possible. Business name, URL, reason added.
So for example, this would be like Google ads, current position. You could put where they're at
organically. Just kind of some notes, those types of things. We're going to get into a lot of this
stuff. Like for this first bit, okay? All I want you to really focus on is the business name,
the URL, why they were added. Okay? Those are the things. And in a future video, we're going to talk
about their position, their email address, their phone number, their Facebook page, notes, business
owner name, business owner Facebook profile. We're going to get into deep depth there. A little bit
of stocking, a little bit of Facebook stocking, you know what I mean? But for this one, I just want
a list of business names, URLs, reason added. So we're going to go through Google ads. We're going
to go through home advisor. We're going to go through Angie's list, et cetera. Now with Google ads,
I do want to let you guys know that you need to be careful. Because a lot of these people, they look
like, you know, for example, this person, the Diamond Solution, they are paying for ads. But
if you look at it really closely, these guys do not do residential concrete. These guys do
massive parking lots and massive parking lots are usually a referral based thing. So this is not
somebody I'm going to want to put on my list as much as I would like to. Another company that I
found, Gold Family Contractors, when you look at it, you're like, oh, it's whatever, whatever. And
then you start realizing, okay, this is a stock image, free quote. This looks a lot like a,
um, yeah, this looks a lot like a lead generation site. Oh my gosh. Um, you know, even though he's
got a picture of himself, whatever, this is actually a lead generation site. And you've
read down here, it says, tell us about your project. We connect you with trained professionals,
et cetera, et cetera. So this is a lead generation site. So I'm not going to add this one. Okay.
So you're just going to start going through, you're going to add anyone that's paying for
Google ads. It looks like a good option. Okay. And then I want to show you, um, once we get to
the home advisor stuff, what you're going to do is you're going to click on the home advisor.
Again, if they're, if home advisors running an ad, do not click on their ad. I know they suck and
I hate them too, but guys, I just, I'm a big believer in this karma thing. Don't click on
their ad and then people won't click on yours. At least that's how I feel. Okay. So if you want to
find home advisor, you're going to go to that. They're listing in the organic results, which is
really simple. Click on this. Okay. And they're just going to, you're going to start seeing, uh,
people in this. Now, one thing to be really, really careful of is to make sure number one,
it's the right niche. So for example, this darling house is, it says something, lift my house. This
is probably a, it is a peer foundation company. So it's technically kind of concrete. That's not
really a company that, that I'm that interested in because they're running their, their foundation
repair company. Okay. JB construction and maintenance services. Okay. Uh, we found
J and B after a bad experience bait and switch, blah, blah, blah. So this could be somebody
interesting. So for this one, what I'm going to do is I'm going to go ahead and just copy this
and I'm going to open a new window and I'm going to check it out. Okay. I'm not a robot. Looks like
I'm searching a lot. So I think I'm a robot. Okay. J and B construction. This looks like a real
company. Let's go ahead and look at their website though. First. Okay. Okay. These guys, Arizona
based full, full service contractor. Yeah. These guys look like they do a lot more than just
concrete, which is fine. But a lot of times when they're doing more than just concrete,
you are going to have people, they don't, they don't want the concrete. They want,
they want the whole job. So this isn't really someone I'm going to, I'm going to hold on that
one. I'm going to keep looking Arizona foundation solutions. Again, that's the foundation company.
No, thank you. McDowell landscaping. Okay. Perfect. That would be somebody that would be
interesting. They're, they're a landscaping company. So I'll check them out and guys,
take your time. Treat these like these are people you're going to be working with for a while.
Now, one thing to note here, McDowell, look at their, their deal here. If you're wondering like,
Oh, does this company actually cover this area? It does say, you know, McDowell landscaping in
Queen Creek. So it does cover there, but make sure it's in the right area. Again, this also
kind of looks to me, this puts off a little bit of a, of a lead generation vibe. So here's what I
want to tell you guys. Okay. I want you to look for lead generation companies, be aware of them,
but if, when in doubt, pick up the phone and go like this 480-878-9569. Okay. We're going to call
them. Okay. So I have a weird area code. I'm sure that's why I answered. He did say Mike McDowell.
So he's a real company. This looks like a real company to me. I'm seeing a lot of stuff about
Queen Creek. This to me looks like a real company. The only thing I would be hesitant of is making
sure that they actually did concrete. So what I'll probably do is I'll text them and say,
Hey, do you guys do patios and driveways? Okay. And you'll probably call me back,
but I want to make sure. So this is somebody I would add. Okay. And so what I would do here is
I would add it's McDowell landscaping. You got to be a little bit careful because a lot of these
guys, they just want like specific type of jobs, especially in this market. But what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to put, you know, okay, I'm going to put the McDowell McDowell landscaping,
and then I'm going to put home advisor. Boom. Okay. So I'm just making a list. Okay. And again,
we're going to be coming back and also why you're, while you're here, what I would say
is grab the phone number so you don't have to come back. So you're already on the site.
Do grab the phone number. And if you see an email, grab it, don't go searching too hard,
but grab the phone number so you don't have to come back to the website. So there's the phone
number and he said, and also he said Mike McDowell. So I'm just going to write it down
because he said it in his voicemail. So no reason to track that down later. So anyway,
we're just going to start building the list. Again, use your intuition.
Um, look for lead generators, look for people that, um, you know, they're not in your area.
That's one big thing that I've noticed is, and they're going to be in California.
They didn't check the setting that says, you know, to not show them other places. You click
on their thing. They're actually in San Francisco and they're running ads in it in Arizona. It's
ridiculous, but it happens. And then when in doubt, I think the biggest thing I would say is just
when in doubt, just call, just call and ask, say, Hey Mike, this is, uh, this is Nick. Just curious.
Do you guys cover Queen Creek? Okay. Cool. Um, was curious. Do you also do, um, do you do flat
work? Do you do patios and driveways, that kind of thing? Okay. Awesome. Well, I have, you know,
you can say whatever I have client, like you don't need to pitch them right there. In fact,
I would recommend you don't pitch them right there, but you say, okay, sounds good. I'll give
you a call back. Let me talk to my spouse. Something very, very simple. But what I want
you guys to do is I want you to start off and I want you to have, I want you to start building a
list of people and my, as I said in a previous video, get as many people as you possibly can
from Google ads and then go to home advisor and then goes to Angie's list, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera. And in the next videos, we're going to talk about what happens if you can't find a bunch
of people running Google ads? What happens if you can't find a bunch of people running, um,
advertising on these different platforms? What do you do then?